chapeau drapeau quand de brume ce
vendredi 13 juillet carlo supporters de
l'équipe de france a décidé de s'équiper
aux couleurs des bleus pour soutenir les
tricolores contre la croatie ce dimanche
15 juillet c'est important ces fermes
ont manqué faut marquer c'est un moment
que fethi festif même sur le père fait
important de marquer le coup c'est le
foot quand on aime le foot on a besoin
d'avoir tout ça avec nous ça n'a pas
tout ça dans une finale de foot c'est
pas en finale carlos n'est pas le seul à
vouloir préparer ce rendez vous depuis
la qualification de la france pour la
finale sept boutiques de déguisements de
maurepas voit déferler des hordes de
supporters ils frisent la rupture de
stock sur certains produits
le best-seller le drapeau tricolore
drapeau c'est énorme on est livrés tous
les jours on essaie de se faire livrer
tous les jours on pleure avec les
fournisseurs pour être librement
on a une raison court encore aujourd'hui
on aura à peu près 300 qu'est ce qui va
arriver du drapeau du drapeau du nord
power derniers préparatifs également
pour les restaurants et les bars ici à
montigny le bretonneux à deux jours de
la finale le gérant montrent un support
pour installer un écran géant à
l'extérieur de l'établissement
objectif pouvoir accueillir plus de 300
supporters
le plus grand moment de l'histoire du
bar et le plus grand moment de
l'histoire de la coupe du monde après 98
on espère revivre sans encore une
nouvelle fois avec le plus de monde
possible
voilà on attend les clients très
nombreux la joie la bonne humeur la
festivité le plus important est de toute
façon nous quoiqu'il arrive les équipes
sont prêtes prêts à vous accueillir
donc c'est que du bonheur il ne reste
plus qu'à attendre une victoire de la
france contre la croatie en finale ce
dimanche 15 juillet à 17 heures pour que
la fête soit encore plus belle
[Applaudissements]